you know sometimes when people hear
about the work that I'm doing about sort
of taking these tasks and fragmenting
them and helping us make use of our
mobile time they're like Jamie you're
gonna ruin my life I'm gonna have to
work all the time it's like all of a
sudden I can't like sit quietly in line
at Starbucks I have to be doing work
then too and that's not actually what
I'm trying to do you're listening to the
Microsoft Research podcast a show that
brings you closer to the cutting edge of
technology research and the scientists
behind it
I'm your host Gretchen using us our
guest today has a lot to say about
productivity in a fragmented culture and
some solutions that seem promising if
somewhat counterintuitive
dr. Jamie teefin is a Microsoft
researcher University of Washington
affiliate professor and the mother of
four young boys today she talks about
what she calls the productivity
revolution and explains how her research
in micro productivity making use of
short fragments of time to help us
accomplish larger tasks could help us be
more productive and experience a better
quality of life at the same time that
and much more on this episode of the
Microsoft Research podcast
[Music]
hey James hi guys give the listeners a
short description of the research you do
I do research thinking about how to use
artificial intelligence to make people
more productive so I'm essentially
thinking about how you can complete your
tasks better by working with the
computer your research addresses
solutions to getting work done in an era
of fragmentation yes at least in part
why do you think things are so
fragmented now and how is it different
from like quote-unquote bad attention
spans of previous eras well so certainly
things are very fragmented right now in
that we get a lot of interruptions we
have we actually do a lot of self
interruptions as well so we might be
sitting at our computer and you'll get a
little toast to notification telling you
have new mail and you're like oh I want
to check that or your phone might beep
to tell you somebody mentions you on
Facebook and you'll go check that or
your phone will ring or somebody will
swing by your office and want to talk so
there's all sorts of interruptions that
are available not just from the people
around us but also from our electronic
devices things are also fragmented
partly because we have mobility so we
have access to information and our work
anywhere we are so if we're at a meeting
or stand in line at Starbucks or if
we're you know commuting home we have
access to information about our work
available there which is why you see
everybody with their head in their phone
which is why you see everybody with
their head in their phone is it
different has technology affected the
kind of fragmentation that we experience
so it's certainly different in the short
term in that kind of traditional
industrialized information work has been
really focused on having these good
solid blocks of time for us to get work
done we pushed towards that that's our
schools are developed that's how our
work is structured and we try hard to
kind of cling to that we you know block
large chunks of time on our calendar so
that we can get as focused work time or
we take Facebook vacations or email
vacations we work really hard to get at
this sort of unfragmented time but in
some ways when you look way back but you
know sort of pre-industrial revolution
you'll actually see that we can we
attended we this kind of
fragmentation or lack of attention is a
positive thing if you think about like
hunter-gatherers it's a good thing to be
attending to the Bobcat in the woods it
might be harmful for you you know so
that kind of fragmentation is actually a
good thing it's the way we work and so
that's what we're trying to do with our
research you know the thing that people
are doing right now in the face of this
fragmentation is essentially trying to
force themselves to work in a none
fragmented manner and what we're trying
to do instead is shatter the tasks
fragment the tasks and then have them go
and match the way that we're actually
working so we take these large complex
tasks and break them down into small
little pieces so that we can start
inserting them into the holes let me go
back to something you said in a paper
that I read you observe that we seem to
be in a constant battle with ourselves
for our own attention your research is
in part at least providing technological
solutions that you've eluded to that
just now but talk a little bit more
about I'm a writer with six open browser
tabs uh-huh you have my full attention
yeah it's interesting even when you
think you've got your focused and paying
attention you have six open browser tabs
so we actually self interrupt in that
way as well not just going to attend to
email but we only focus on any window
that's shown to us for like less than a
minute you know so as you're working
you're switching between applications
you're switching across things as well
actually each of these little things
that you do are essentially a micro task
that works to make part of your larger
task that you're doing and what's
important in order to be able to move
between those micro tasks is to kind of
model and understand the context that's
in your head that's necessary to
complete that task and make sure that's
available to you when you move on to the
next step okay so people have complained
that technology is making us distracted
we can't sustain attention we sometimes
need to however
I've read studies that show or say
suggest I think you can't say show and
that we actually should schedule in
breaks and should schedule so does
that's I was reading that you know aside
from anything you've done and then I got
to your stuff goes together yeah it does
actually so you know
sometimes when people hear about the
work that I'm doing about sort of taking
these tasks and fragmenting them and
helping us make use of our mobile time
they're like Jamie you're gonna ruin my
life I'm gonna have to work all the time
it's like all of a sudden can't like sit
quietly in line at Starbucks I have to
be doing work then too and that's not
actually what I'm trying to do we want
to make people efficient at doing tasks
partly by helping them replenish and
recover as well and so we've done a lot
of research that shows breaks are really
important and that we can also help
guide people not only guide people into
being very productive and getting tasks
time but also guide people's state of
mind to help them become to help them
replenish to help them get into you know
where they need to be there was one
study we did where we turned off
everybody's access to Facebook for you
know the whole day we had people kind of
list they're distracted applications and
turn them off for the whole day and we
you know did this over an extended
period of time and we looked at how it
impacted them and it drove them crazy
and it made them so much less productive
because it was just very stressful not
to be able to take breaks or get away or
relax and you can be intentional about
those breaks it and playing Angry Birds
it's not necessarily the most the best
way to kind of replenish your cognitive
resources things like taking a walk
outside are a really good way to do that
Clifford Nass and Stanford did a study
on multitasking yep and it was using
University students who claimed to be
you know Olympic caliber of multitaskers
and it turned out they weren't yep and
he said no they're not multitasking
their tasks switching and each time you
switch a task you have to come back to
the other and it takes away time and
it's not productive how does that go
together with what you're doing on micro
productivity we work at MSR with a bunch
of the world experts on multitasking as
well Sean C Iqbal and Mary sure Winsky
and Gloria mark was just up visiting
from UC Irvine and absolutely 100%
multitasking is ridiculous and you
should never do it that's that's 100%
true let's level set on what
multitasking is my daughter never
doesn't listen to music when she's
studying yeah and she's got texts going
on she gets a snapchat she's you know
doing a thousand
things at once I think she's doing them
all yeah inequality wait she's not yeah
she's not so multitasking is a bad plan
doing tasks serially is a good plan the
way that this fits with our micro
productivity work is we're making the
task so small that you actually could be
doing them you're your it looks like
multitasking sort of at the macro level
and at the micro level you're doing
tasks really it's about including all of
the contexts and all the information
necessary to complete that task in that
small little bit so we actually just ran
a study also on this we built a tool
that helped people do writing tasks in
small little chunks so you might copy
edit a sentence or you might read a
paragraph for flow or that sort of thing
and we had people do that while watching
a video and so we and then we quizzed
them on the video after they were done
with that and so we wanted to see how
well were they able to attend to both
tasks the primary task of watching the
video in the secondary task of trying to
edit a document through either these
little micro tasks that we gave them or
these using a traditional document
editing tool in both cases they were
actually able to answer the questions
about the video just about as well but
they weren't able to make a lot more
edits and in general just feel like the
cognitive load was a lot lower by using
these small little extracted tasks than
they were by trying to do it as a large
piece you know otherwise you're trying
to find where wasn't again and what was
I thinking right rather than now yeah
rather than just having what you needed
to do up front so I think this would be
a good time to do a level set of the
word productivity and when are we
actually ever gonna say we're productive
enough is there some productivity utopia
that we're working toward it is really
interesting to think about up until now
though you know so productivity is
essentially a measure of the output as a
function of the input that you're that
you put into a task and up until now
we're really working to try to help
people produce more output for the same
important it's like there's a sort of
time value you know how do you do things
the most efficiently so like can you
screw in this bolt as efficiently as
possible or can you do this action and
like how do we minimize movements so
that you're even more efficient those
are kind of boring repetitive tasks and
the good news is we're getting really
good at being able to take over those
boring repetitive tasks so in you know
in the context of a factory we couldn't
screw in that bolt we don't need a
person to become super efficient
screwing that bolt in we can have a
robot doing it in information work as we
start breaking down tasks into their
kind of sub structure we can start
identifying those bolts screwing tasks
and we can watch people do them just
like the robots do in the factory and
learn how to do that for them and so
people become useless for those boring
repetitive tasks and instead we become
really valuable for the interesting
thoughtful creative aspects of the tasks
that are that we can't figure out how to
do automatically and that's really cool
so like in the in in our future
productivity utopia we're all artists
and creative thinkers and we're all kind
of thinking about you know making broad
connections and thinking about how
things work together and adding our
unique human insight into the process
[Music]
alright let's switch over you've used
the word sourcing terms of ways to get
work done and there's crowd sourcing and
there's friend sourcing but the most
interesting one you said it's self
sourcing yes and so I like how is that
different from the way I usually sit
down and make myself try to get work
done no it's true most of you know all
of our personal paths that we do
ourselves are essentially self sourcing
so we're sourcing it to ourselves we use
the term self sourcing as as a play on
the word crowdsourcing in the context of
micro productivity so a lot of the early
work in micro productivity are thinking
about how you take a large task and
break it down into these small tasks was
done in the context of crowdsourcing so
these crowdsourcing platforms are ways
to quickly connect with people online to
perform the tasks that you need and the
problem is because they're sort of
short-term relationships that you have
that you bring people in to say help me
with you know I need help photoshopping
this one picture copy editing this
document I wrote it's not a long-term
relationship generally what people have
found is it's very you know you're much
more successful if you provide a lot of
structure so instead of saying please
Photoshop this picture you might ask
somebody to remove the background and
somebody else to you know make the
people in the picture looking better and
somebody else to look at the overall
composition or something like that and
that structure was useful for bringing
other people in and as we looked at it
we were like well actually there's the
opportunity to use that same structure
to make it useful to for myself to sort
of essentially collaborate with myself
over time so how do I provide some
contributions now and some contributions
later
you know sourcing myself now and later
to produce an output so then you're
breaking it down so that you can see
smaller chunks of it and it's not maybe
so overwhelming of a big task to do
we've done work looking at the
difference between doing a task is sort
of this large macro task versus the
exact same task as a series of smaller
micro tasks and what we found was when
when you do a task in micro tasks you
feel like it's easier you produce higher
quality output actually because you sort
of had your externalizing all the work
that you're doing in the context of
these tasks rather than holding it on
your head as you're doing the larger
task and it's more resilient to
interruptions so because there's all
these sort of task boundaries introduced
you're able
to deal with all this sort of incoming
others stuff serializing the little
small micro tasks rather than trying to
do a large task so self sourcing was a
funny phrase for me to encounter when I
started looking into your research
another funny phrase was slow search
uh-huh and I know you've done talks on
this you've done a lot of research on it
basically going back to your beginnings
yeah search and personal search can you
unpack slow search and what that means
and what it's about
slow search is framed in contrast to
fast search which is actually how most
of the search that we do right now is
framed so we've done a lot of studies
looking at the impact of time on how
people find information and one of the
things that we found is if you introduce
really small delays in the search
results that people get like even by a
hundred milliseconds which is actually
imperceptible so people only notice
things they notice delays in their user
interfaces if they're like two or three
hundred milliseconds say if you if you
submit a query to a search engine and we
just hold on to those that query and do
nothing with it for 100 milliseconds and
then start and go and try and return
results people actually perceive those
search result equality is lower so they
think the results are worse they
interact with the search results less
they even come back to the search engine
less often and that's not cuz the
quality is lower it's because we held on
to those results for just 100
milliseconds a delay of something you
can't perceive makes you perceive yet
that it's worse yeah once you figure
that out
search engines invest all sorts of money
and time and effort into giving you
search results a hundred milliseconds
faster because you know we invest a lot
of money in trying to give you better
results but clearly giving you faster
results also makes you happier with the
results so we at Bing for example when
you run a query instead of showing you
ten links so typically the search is
described as ten blue links if you go
and count the number of links it's
actually only eight links and it's
because the page loads that much faster
when we dumb two links off the page and
that makes it seem better for you we're
smart with it so this whole focus on
speed is kind of ironic because actually
half of our search sessions
our multi query multi-session there long
we spend a lot of time you know so these
ones where you're like looking for the
New York Times home page like that's in
and out j.crew yeah exactly but the ones
where you're engaging in a topic those
are longest inin queries so like 100
milliseconds shouldn't really matter
there especially and so we can start
detecting when you're engaged in a
longer session and then we might go and
take a little bit more time to give you
more results be a little more thoughtful
about what you're doing you have a foot
both in academia and Microsoft Research
what do you think are the most exciting
opportunities for this field that you're
working in right now I'm really excited
I think we don't yet know how to help
people interact with computer systems
that aren't always right so one of the
things that's happening is we're able to
do a lot more automatically but we're
getting it wrong a lot and search is
really interesting in this way it's one
of the really few places where we
interact with a computer and there is
ambiguity so when you enter a query and
you get 10 links or eight links you know
that that list isn't you isn't gonna be
a hundred percent correct and actually
people do trust that list a fair amount
you'll say they click on the first
result more and they tend to think that
the first results more relevant than the
fifth result even though it's not
necessarily that much more relevant but
we're aware of that and we're aware it
might be imperfect and we are aware that
we need to have a conversation and
iterate with a search engine there's
almost nowhere else in our interactions
with computers where that's true where
that ambiguity that fact that it might
be wrong as present and we need to fix
that because we can't be providing
doctors with support for diagnosing
people if they're gonna take that to be
true they need it to be they need to
understand the you know what the
computer is wrong about and doesn't know
and be able to kind of work together
that way and what's more is we need
people to help teach the computers so
that they can be better next time and so
that each time there's an interaction
with the same big Uwe T the next time it
it responds in them a little bit more
appropriate way which leads me to an
interesting you had a big slide deck
that I think you've done from a
presentation and you said computers are
good at
this yet people are good at this yeah so
talk about that so there are some things
that computers are really good at you
know we don't and I find it very
interested actually just thinking about
like AI and intelligence when I computed
the things that we don't think of that
as intelligence and that's not like a
computer can do a really large numeric
computation I'm like if you could do
that off the top of your head I'd be
like wow that's amazing but like a
computer can do it you're like all right
whatever right you know a computer in
the context of search can look at you
know millions and billions of documents
and you certainly couldn't do that even
if you spent the rest of your life just
starting to look at all the documents
that's something that computers are
really good at computers are not so good
at synthesizing and understanding things
that's something that people are good at
we're good at seeing the big picture
we're good at understanding connections
and one of the things that you know and
certainly we'd like computers to be good
at that or better at that and we and
we've got a lot of research going into
that space but I think it's a really
cool instead to think about how to bring
humans and computers together so that
you get this creative synthesis and
big-picture insight from people and you
get this like really amazing ability to
do large-scale computation from
computers and I mean you know honestly
we we kind of get this in our own world
right now in that we're all smarter
because of the internet and so you know
it's really a waste keyword search is a
way that we're pulling together this
large-scale computation of computers
with our own ability so we're
externalise a lot of our knowledge we
don't have to know you know where every
country in the world is or we don't know
have to know every medical term because
we can go look that up and then we can
use our insights to understand the world
better I like the the things that I read
about what you're doing bringing people
and computers together and it's not so
much computers replacing humans but more
augmenting and helping tell me what your
sort of big picture on that as as you do
your work in Microsoft Research what's
your vision for what computers and
humans can do together this productivity
utopia that you are talking about a
little bit earlier you know I think
we we can make the world a better place
you know I don't know I don't really
know how to answer this without sounding
trite I think you go for it you know
it's just yes we can we can accomplish
all the things we've been accomplishing
more we can do it easier we can be rich
in cognitive resources because we're not
doing other things and we can really be
maximizing the the way we think about
the world and the way we interact with
people and the way that we you know move
society forward what would you like
people to know about your research that
you think they might not know and just
Microsoft research in general Microsoft
is a company that touches a lot of
different sectors and a lot of different
reasons I mean Microsoft research we're
doing all sorts of stuff so it's you
know it's not like I do research related
to search and task completion but
there's other people who are doing work
you know related to quantum computing
and other people doing research related
to you know cryptography there's all
sorts of different you know we have Imus
we have ethnographers and
anthropologists like there's just a
broad range of people looking at it you
know looking at DNA and how we can you
know encode information in DNA there's
all sorts of it's a really broad
organization because we're thinking
about the larger company which really
has a broad impact on the world what is
it the most excites you about micro
productivity I guess well you know I
have four little kids I am really
excited about being able to make
productive use of my time
so that I can hang out with them and
also be able to use the small little
bits where I'm with them that I'm not
attendant like actually I mean this
makes me sound like a terrible parent I
go to the playground with my kids and
they're playing on the playground and I
know some people think you should go
engage with your children the whole time
they're on that but you know what I'm
kind of like that's my time for my kids
to be running around and for me to sit
and be quiet and you know what I do like
I take out my phone check my email
and that takes about five minutes and
then I'm done and then I have nothing to
do so then I start playing candy crush
and I'm on level like two thousand five
hundred and overachiever
um and I would much rather be using that
time to be productive cuz you know what
I'm actually with my kids at the
playground which is nice and I'm out
decide if I can get stuff done then and
like take that out of my workday that
would be awesome right well back in the
day I mean talk about bad parents it's
like they sent us out to play with no
helmet
well they sing in/sign had a cigarette
no martini right yeah you know phone
it's not that I mean they need their own
space I mean it's just the point is it
allows me to put my work into sort of
these dead times and you know it's
basically defragging my life where I
have some dead time and that dead time
exists while I'm at work or while I'm at
home and I if I can use that
productively then I can use my whole
life the way that I want to use it you
know earlier I was thinking we feel
guilty when we aren't engaged with our
work via a mobile device or a laptop or
whatever and then we feel guilty when we
are engaged with the device because we
should be with people and it's not cool
I think we need to figure out a way to
get rid of the active guilt I agree
that's like my big piece of advice they
give when people are like you have any
advice for me I'm like don't feel guilty
I mean just think I mean like do you
know you can use guilt as a signal to be
like you need to change but you should
also be forgiving of yourself and you
should be like I need breaks I need time
at work I need time at home like just
respect all of that variation and that
way you capitalize on it like if it's
time that you're spending at home like
recharge then embrace that use that to
for what it is and and when it's time
you're spending at work or when you know
or if it's time you're like I need to
just like lay in bed and watch Netflix
like that's a fine thing if that's what
you need to do you know yeah and on this
by the same token stop judging people
you know if they're on their screen cuz
you're at the playground looking at some
other mom going yeah well she's probably
you know now and I'm parents are the
worst about being judgmental other but
yeah I'm doing something really
productive on my phone and you're just
no sir oh my god we actually did a study
that looked at how people perceived
their other people
use a phone compared to their own use of
phone so we looked at device uses and
meetings and we found that people are
like I use my devices for very
productive things everybody else in the
meeting is you see their devices to goof
off what is funny we totally think
everybody else is greener it's like
biblical the plank in the Splinter yeah
but then again I would actually also say
forgive yourself for being a little
judgy sometimes too I mean we're all
kind of just you know recognize that for
what so the overarching thing is grace
yeah thank you so much for coming in I
really enjoy talking to you and as a
matter of fact we will try to get the
little party together and maybe we can
all sit around on our screens to learn
more about Jamie TV's work along with
other research that can make your life
more productive disap Microsoft comm
slash research
[Music]